so you can see here you have to be
careful with your integrals right by the
way one last little thing we shouldn't
be all that surprised that this area kia
is going to be zero if we just approach
it as an integral right what kind of
function is the original function that
we are what fun kind of function is the
integrand it's not just any kind of
function this has a particular kind of
symmetry right
it's the integrand the integrand that
the function that I integrated is odd
yes do you agree with that now therefore
we've been thinking about like that just
in terms of rotation okay but in terms
of integration if you have an odd
function that an area over here would be
always exactly opposite to an area over
here right because that's the way an odd
function looks so if you're getting the
exact opposites remember if this is odd
what do you expect the primitive to be
even because remember we proved that the
derivative of an even function is odd
and the derivative of an odd function is
even so going this way you get an even
function and you're evaluating it at
exactly opposite points right so you're
going to get the same thing which is why
when you take the difference you get
zero okay so in fact this is actually a
property that we're going to think I
might even write it if you evaluate any
integral from opposite x-values right
it'll always be zero if f of X is odd do
you agree with that like this is the
actual case that we looked at right if
you have a function and it's an odd
function okay when you go from a
negative x value to the same positive x
value those areas will exactly cancel
out so that integral will always equal
zero okay I wonder what conclusion you
would draw if I said do the same thing
if it were even what kind of statement
could you make if I actually had an even
function rather than an odd one think
about a picture in your head
very good before I write that down let
me quickly get you to get a picture in
your head if you're not quite seeing it
think about a classical even function
like say x squared okay if you evaluate
from any negative value and the same
positive values so you know somewhere
here and somewhere over here
okay then because it's an even function
these are the same area it's a copy
just reflected across the y-axis right
so therefore I don't necessarily have to
work it out for a - a - a if I just work
it out from zero to a I can just double
that thing okay so I would say over here
it's double here to go from zero to a if
okay now it might seem like oh this is
extra why why memorize extra rules about
things okay well I wouldn't if you can
see why this is really great because it
just shortcut I don't even have to do
any integration any primitives or
whatever if I know it's odd I don't
write like for example we don't know how
to differ it or integrate any of the
trig functions yet not yet okay but I
can know like which trig functions are
odd functions just this there's a couple
which one would you pick is an example
sine sine is an odd function right so if
I went from say oh I don't know um
- one - one okay that's fine I don't
even talk about the units yet get to
that but if I integrate from the same
value negative to the same value
positive where you'd respect X I don't
know anything about what the premium of
wait but I know that the area will be
zero or on the integral is zero okay
because the appliance it is I wonder if
you can see why this is also handy why
is this a handy thing to do
if I have number one if I'm even
fortunate that makes it simpler but also
see the snow-mickey yeah that's kind of
nice I like putting in 0 wherever I
possibly can because 0 is always really
easy to evaluate right it's like I'm
trying to make work easier for me rather
have to evaluate two numbers I just
really have to evaluate one and a very
simple value okay
so we're gonna get some more of these
but this is just the classic example
that comes out of this particular if you
gave me an example then I could
okay so X cubed - 0 9 and then - okay
okay no it is okay yes yes so what the
key is talking about is actually
something plants I mentioned to you too
today but since it was raised I might as
well you can talk about like let's look
at this guy over here remember right I
broke this one up this area I break it
up into two slices okay there's no
reason why I can't do that because I'm
just talking about areas you can divide
an area up into however many slices
you'd like okay now being that I've
integrated from four to nine if I wanted
to I could consider it let's just done
I'll just consider this part for a
minute just
it's it's easy to do it okay there's no
reason why I can't say hmm this is
important I'm here's a simpler version
of um this is not excellent next to the
four but it's close enough but I'm just
going to hijack it
okay so maybe for tonight it's something
like that it's that area there okay
clearly that area is the same as this
area here all the way from the origin
takeaway in this area that I've just
shaded in blue right because I'm just
taking the difference in two areas so if
I wanted to I could say that this
integral is this big integral that's
from not tonight right and then take
away this blue one in here right which
is from not to form okay no in this case
it actually doesn't help and I'll show
you why okay putting in the zeros it's
great zeros are easy to evaluate but I'm
still going to have to evaluate it at
night for this integrand and then I'm
going to have to evaluate at four with
this one which is exactly what I was
going to do with the original integral
right so actually in this case it is not
advantageous but later on breaking up an
integral into two integrals just like we
have done here actually is tremendously
useful okay and the fact that you can do
it comes from the fact that we just
thinking about areas and do everything
with areas sorry everything with
integrals that you can do in areas like
slices over the pieces
if you're just area we also just like
reduce the even function um yes you can
yes you can
so in in say this case if I've got an
even I just you know I just take one and
I take the other however the problem is
like how many times out of all the
functions that you encounter how many of
them end up being exactly odd and how
many end up being exactly even often
they just off just by a little bit it's
like just enough so you can't use these
properties in exactly the way that you
described you probably actually have to
do it this way
you just have to break it up into one
piece and another piece that isn't
exactly the same okay like for example
if I just change this up boundaries if I
just changed it to two you can't use it
anymore right because I've changed the
boundaries right yeah you're still gonna
have to slice it up right yeah you can
you can do this part and then this part
using what you're talking about but you
still have two parts you might as well
just have done the negative one and the
positive one okay so now one last thing
you remember we said okay
differentiation and integration those
two things are opposite to each other
okay so I'm going to start talking about
anti-differentiation now because par the
reason why I didn't talk about it was
because you didn't know what integration
was okay he's how I trying to
conceptually understand what's going on
if you think back to our speed distance
entire thing yesterday okay and this is
worth writing down differentiation right
differentiation gives you gradient okay
that makes sense we really wrapped our
heads around that when we did first
principles no big deal okay on the other
hand integration which we do via ad
differentiating in both of those places
right gives your area
now differentiation and integration
right the opposite things okay but it is
not at all obvious that Grady
and area opposite things like how does
that work okay well here's how it works
gradient right gradient is really about
how you change you write what's your
rate of change that's what speed is all
it is right oh how is your position
changing every hour and the answer is
that 60 kilometres every hour I change
by 60 points that's what 60 Plummers per
hour
means so that would be the gradient of
my travel rapidly
great it means how are you changing
Arion right is also about change but
it's not about how you're changing at
any particular point it's about what is
your total change that's what I was
trying to get across to you well yeah
that's right when we looked at when we
looked at that on that tram government
oh look that area down there is 25 times
- 25 times 2 is 50 what was the
significance of that number 4 and the
answer was it was 130 takeaway ad like
the total amount of distance that I've
changed
which is why total change of 0 makes
sense a lot at the time because if you
do something like this and they do it
give it moves right and then do it in
reverse of course the total change will
be zero right you go to the left and
then you go to the right and you're back
where you started
ok so really this is about change in an
instant
right at that particular moment in time
and this is about change add it up over
a period of time and that's how they're
opposites right so this tells you that
something isn't aeneas and this tells
you about like talking about the total
okay they're really both about change
and that's why all the contexts that
you're going to apply this to when it's
not just random functions but they're
actually about things like populations
or objects that are moving or all those
kinds of examples they're all about how
are they changing calculus is the
mathematics of change